Megan we know now it seems that it's a
good day for Ted Cruz and full Bernie
Sanders yeah I mean this has ended up
pretty much as we expected I think a few
people are holding out for a surprise we
had early calls in both these races in
one case with Bernie Sanders and that
were called it immediately if Fox did
reflect about the huge turnout he got
and the sort of surge and supportive got
from that highly educated to pay that
young demographic there and with Ted
Cruz this is a big win a possible
turning point in the stop Trump movement
and people would not be turning looking
to exactly how each congressional
district plays out to see how the
delegates shape out and as we head
towards New York on April nineteenth
right but Sir what about Ted Cruz
they're looking at that one how much is
this slow Donald Trump down look it
slows them down we're going to have to
see the final count which we haven't
seen yet in terms of see how these
delegates are awarded in Wisconsin but
Trump does have a huge lead in New York
and there's a lot of people who argue
that really Trump hasn't been slowed by
the stop Trump momentum what he's been
slowed as this lull in the primary
counter we've had these long weeks
between contests Wisconsin was never
going to be an easy state for him it has
a highly educated electorate much higher
than some other states it was more
favorable to Ted Cruz in many respects
it was always going to be a tough fight
and he did have a bad week last week I
think we go to New York people are
expecting him the early polls show that
he'll take over fifty percent there when
he considers his home state and that
will be the big next test in this in
this election to see whether or not he
can win the nomination outright or we're
going to a contested convention